[Music]
hey everyone welcome to et live I'm
Liana Giller and I'm so thrilled because
today Lucy Hale from life sentence is
joining us today hi Luce hello ru yeah
lovely to see you too thank you so much
for stopping by yeah it's fine I know so
for all the fans who are tuning in right
now send us your questions for Lucy I
will be delivering them to her but first
we have to talk all about life sentence
let's do it it has been such a
delightfully fun show it's like a breath
of fresh air on the CW right now yeah I
mean we were just chatting about it
earlier it's such a unique and different
show for the CW and you know we're sort
of finding our place of where we fit in
in the network and you know the people
that are watching are loving it so it's
great that it's it's slowly but surely
finding its audience and I'm just
grateful because it is such a
extraordinary story and I love these
characters I love the places that they
go there's so many topics that really
spoke to me so I hope that they're
speaking to other people so I really
hope that it's continues to like gain
traction and then people give it the
chance that it deserves it's it's got a
special place in my heart for sure
well one of the things that I'm excited
about but also apprehensive about is
that this week's episode West Side Story
is going to be bringing a blast from
Wes's past yes what can you tease for
the fans yeah I mean throughout this
story it is about a girl who's given a
second chance at life but the foundation
of it is this love story between Stella
and Wes and they seemingly have had like
a perfect little relationship many
relationship little you know any
relationship that's now gonna become a
lot larger yeah and it never crosses
Stella's mine that Wes has been in love
before that Wes has ever been engaged
before that he said the same things to
Stella that you know that he said those
other words to someone else and it's a
it's a little bit of a shock that we
find out his ex-fiancee she comes into
town and sort of rocks
Stella's world because she's charming
she's British she's gorgeous and I don't
think Stella quite knows to do
what to do with all this information
yeah I love that Stella naturally
because of what she's been going through
in her life and her family really wanted
to protect her because she was already
going through such a difficult situation
she hasn't been kind of kept in a bubble
oh yeah
and yeah so that bubble has now popped
it's definitely I mean it popped the day
that she got the news that she was gonna
survive and then over the course of the
next couple of weeks you just see all
these things start piling up on her life
that she had no idea about and as you
can imagine it's it's a little
overwhelming for one person to handle so
you know you'll get to see how Stella
Hands handles all this information
especially it's got to be difficult if
you accidentally catch fields for
someone well that's the other thing is
she then Stella never really had time to
have a crush on someone or not or date
someone and you know there were no
dating apps for her so now that she's
got the rest of her life she starts
seeing people in a new light and she
definitely starts developing feelings
for dr. grant who is Sadie she befriends
this little girl Sadie and it's it's her
oncologist and yes and she you know she
denies it for a really long time she
pushes it away but it's just dr. grant
understands Stella in a way that Wes
never could and so yeah we were just
talking about the last line he delivered
was I wish I had met you seven months
ago and Riley was like how do I Riley
who plays dr. grant was like how do I
deliver this in a way that is not creepy
yeah weird and it left me with the
impression like I want to see more of
them together so you get to see this
it's more of like a love square because
Wes and Pippa like develop something
again and then there's a lot of a lot of
stuff going on here but I think you feel
so torn at this point because ya know
like dr. grant and syllabi have this
instantaneous chemistry but at the same
time marriage is marriages marriage yeah
there are rules to marriage what has it
been like for you jumping into a brand
new show that is not of murders every
other I mean I it's so it's so bizarre
to not be less with a cliffhanger of who
died this week you know it's
such a different experience and that
before we started this I was telling you
it's it's so bizarre to kick start a new
show off the ground that didn't you know
with PLL it had a following before it
was even a show it was a book series and
so to literally start something off the
ground and to get people's attention and
to get people on the bandwagon has been
a big challenge but it's been very fun
you know this is totally so different
from PLL and although I'm had the time
of my life on that show it's been nice
to step away and and do different things
and play different characters and you
know I think the character Aria will
follow me around forever and I'm totally
cool and fine with that but that's a
cool care nice to mix it up yeah we're
starting to get in so many great fan
questions Charlotte from YouTube wants
to know what do you want the fans to
take away from life sentence Oh
Charlotte that's a great question um for
me I I wanted to take on this role
because hey I love strong independent
female characters and Stella is all
those things but she's also really
flawed and really lost and you know is
figuring out where she fits in into the
world and I think we can all relate to
that you know the whole moral of this
show is like when life gives you lemons
make lemonade yeah and I think that we
can all do a little bit more of that in
our life and I think that overall this
show deals with so many heavy topics but
they do it all with the sense of humor
and they do it all with their family and
friends as their backbone and I think
that it's just got a lot of heart to it
I don't want people to sort of not take
you know to take away from the show that
we are not guaranteed anything and we
should be grateful for every
relationship every moment that we have
definitely yeah we're starting to see a
little bit of like a divide in the
comments right now so Daria from YouTube
says Stella and dr. grant should be
together okay ash from facebook says I'm
loving life sentence but I'm so torn
between Stella and Wes and Stella and
dr. grant
who
you have the most instant chemistry with
onset oh it's so tough it's so tough
because I as Stella was like well can't
she just have two husbands like lay on
both of these fields a little bit she's
using like I have I have great chemistry
with both of them but in very different
ways like Riley brings us like super
masculine like vibe and then there's
Elliott who like I immediately met him
was like we're gonna be best friends
forever and we are for like he's one of
my dearest friends so it was fun to get
to play around with two different types
of chemistry and I I can't say like
which side I lean more towards but I
definitely have one more toys I just
don't want to say it out loud said I
won't hurt anyone's feelings but I
definitely like Timbo yes and you get to
see her sort of struggle with who should
I be with interest yeah mm-hmm well the
nice thing about it is that you and your
co-stars get along you all are like
Instagram photos and everything what
does that been like for you like truly a
dream job I am so hopeful that we get to
go back and make more episodes purely
from the fact that of course I love the
characters and I love the story I love
these people so much we had the best
time yeah and it's been you know a much
different dynamic than PLL where it was
all female like this cast is female and
male of all ages um you know we have
little kids you know and then there's
Dylan washer please dad so like we're
kind of all over the map
it's great it's nice I'm I recognize
that it's not always like that on set so
anytime it is I count my blessings and
you know hope that it stays that way
well and I loved that you recently
reconnected with Ian Harding and you
share don't make sure I know it like the
Internet I had no didn't realize it was
gonna be that reaction but where were
you guys and what was it like to reunite
I was in Chicago and Ian is filming a
Fox pilot out there I think I don't know
the name of it but it's the Katie Holmes
Fox pilot night so I'm very excited for
him and he was actually staying at the
same hotel that I was and we kept
missing each
so finally who texted was like I'm
downstairs creepily drinking coffee
under the stairwell so I immediately saw
him because I knew exactly where he'd be
um it was good I hadn't seen him in a
long time so we just caught up and you
know catching up on life lovely very
happy for him I love you in so much how
do you feel about where Aria left off on
Piolo I mean they got married so I think
that that you know I imagine you know
that they're off somewhere living there
you know boring married couple life but
but also at the same time I have a
feeling that turmoil is just happening
for these girls all over again yeah so
we'll see well now I'm very curious to
see the spin-off exactly yeah and which
leads us to psoralen from YouTube says
would you ever make an appearance on
perfectionist and everyone's loving your
hair by the way guys guys I rarely wear
it straight but I love you questions
what did you say a perfectionist yes
yeah absolutely I you know I talked to
Janelle and Sasha quite a bit and I keep
in touch with Marlene yeah and nobody
will really tell me what the show is
about so I'm very curious to see how
they're bringing these two characters
into like a whole new world of the
perfectionist cuz I haven't read that
book but they're two very different
worlds so they're like meshing them
together yeah I think Arya would
definitely you know I would definitely
be on that show I am stoked for them and
I hope it does well and equally as
curious as everyone out there I see what
they do and that they haven't told you
anything so many secrets it's one of the
lot but you know like the whole thing
was on PLoS I was always the last one to
know and that's that's a conscious
decision though big and I do that on
life's and it's to you I want on it it
to affect your performance by know the
ending of you know Troy's character like
that would have you can see it looking
better but it would yeah somewhere in
the back of my mind would have affected
how I've played it you know I always try
not to to know too much when you look
back on PLL is there an episode or a
scene that you wish you could revisit or
redo almost oh that's a good question
I always to this day my favorite episode
is the pilot and I just wish I could go
back to doing the pilot knowing the
success that it would have yeah
just because pilots are so weird and so
scary because you do them and you're
like there's no job security ever you're
like we have to be dealt X amount of
other shows and then then even when it's
on the air you don't know if it's gonna
be a hit so pilots are always weird you
never really enjoy them because you
don't you just don't know just so I
would love to go back to that episode
being my favorite episode just cuz it it
set up the story in the world perfectly
I thought it was a perfect episode and
but I wish I could go back and like
enjoy it more and be like huh I'm gonna
be on the air for eight more years
instead of worrying about like my next
paycheck or also even just be like have
fun in the bathroom scene oh yeah I was
so nervous so nervous because at that
point I had a crush on Ian because we
had just met and I was super I was like
twenty years old I would have had a
crush on any cute boy that was around
and yeah we we definitely probably could
have gone for it more in that scene
though I loved it every game yes
well and then one more in a question for
you Andrew from YouTube wants to know
did aria and Ezra have kids will they
have kids I imagine I imagine so
yes I could see them like having
triplets or something accidentally and
like not on purpose like just we're like
let's have a baby
but they end up having three I could see
that for sure and I imagine them living
somewhere desolate like away from the
craziness and like her knitting and him
doing whatever he does what does he do
for a living he's a t-shirt yeah yeah
but he's an author he's an author I know
that he riding his boat yeah Oh Rachel
says Lucy I love your music thank you I
do - Crito
and she said you tweeted last week that
lie a little better was about drew yeah
did you mean drew van Acker from PLL and
also
love you want more music yes I met drew
van Acker so for years people had asked
me what that song was about or who it
was about and I was like I should just
tell them and then I was like no I
should just tease people for a little
bit so for years I didn't tell anyone
and so finally the other week I had like
it came on my shuffle and I was like
yeah the songs about drew I had a crush
on drew yes
yeah years ago did he know he's I know
now yeah sure does not but he's like
happily with someone and it's all like
done with but now the world knows when
drew van Acker he's a cutie he's a
sweetheart - such a nice guy do you find
that when you're working on a show
you're in such close quarters with
people is it easy to fall into crushes
of pee absolutely yeah absolutely I
think that the actors can't stay married
because it's like woo it like almost you
know I'm older now so I can like
differentiate like real life and work
but when you're younger you're you're
you know especially when you're on
location you're like almost forced to
bond with these people in a different
way and play there's a lot of head games
going on and yeah there's been I've had
lots of little show manses before yeah
and then we stopped filming or working
I'm like oh wait I don't really like you
know that was me come show manses
because it's like for the time being
how's love life now Lucy you know I'm
happily spending time with my dog ya
know I will say I'm very happy I'm like
you know life is good in all areas it's
good stuff that made me happy thank you
and I love the fact that you don't
necessarily even need a guy to be happy
in Hollywood no you don't you don't you
really don't I have now figured that out
it 28 years old so love it we are
running out of time but you guys are
still sending so so many great questions
so I'm gonna sneak a couple more in
right now Oh Stephanie from YouTube says
how was it channeling your grandmother
through Tyler the medium oh yes so I I
shot this while I was up in Vancouver
Tyler came up there and the whole thing
about this is he never knows who he's
gonna meet is that real it's true it's
true and I couldn't I can say that so he
and he actually didn't even know who I
was when we were done he had no idea he
met me
like I don't know what you do for like
he just didn't know yeah they try to
protect him from you know so he can't
see or whatever it was but I bought into
all of this beforehand I completely
believe in ghosts and you know mediums
and psychics and all that so I wanted to
you know speak with my grandmother and
it took a while to like get there you
know they edit it like an hour down to
like five minutes but yeah I like had
someone write down everything he was
saying because there was a bunch of
things that weren't making sense and
towards the end I was like oh my gosh
like little things down - he brought up
a puppet and my grandmother used to like
play with these finger puppet so it was
like very weird details and it's not
like what I thought it was gonna be I
thought it was gonna be him saying your
grandmother says she loves you and she
misses you but it's not that direct it's
more like he was getting all these good
memories that her and I shared and then
there was a bunch of other stuff that
you know dealt with other people but
he's incredible it's really bizarre to
be in his presence when he's channeling
all this because he sweats profusely and
he like he doodles he like has to write
and it it's it's a little creepy I'm a
lie but it's he definitely has a gift
it's very cool yeah we're gonna wrap
this on an amazing note because I want
to know this - the pace from YouTube
says will there be any new music soon I
would love that
uh.well album wise hopefully in the next
couple of years but I well this hasn't
even been announced yet but I think you
can tell it doing well I'm doing a film
where I play a singer it's like an
animated film so there will be some
music there but I would love the thing
about me and music is I never want it to
feel forced or like oh this seems like
the right thing to do I wanted to feel
very authentic and like I when I have
time off to do it so the music will
always be a part of my life I just don't
have like an exact date of when but
definitely soon my note I hate hearing
soon yeah because whatever but I would
like a trio between you Janelle and
Sasha done I love those girls they
better be in - thank you all so much for
chatting with Lucy
and I and be sure to keep it locked to
the CW because life-sentence airs
Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m. and then it's
gonna bump over to Fridays at 9:00 p.m.
correct yes
yeah all right fantastic bye guys we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]